let's go to number five
types of enviro so the first envir
uh i think was pete's point it's called
the leveler
and the leveler will tear down anyone
that's achieved
something great and try to bring them
down to their mediocre level
they'll never see and appreciate
excellence in
anybody unless they're dead
these levelers i mean you gotta
it doesn't even matter if they're i
don't even care if it's a family member
i don't care if it's a best friend that
you've been with for you know
20 years of your life and you were
brothers from another mother in high
school or
anything like that if there's people
in your life that are envious of you and
you start to recognize
these signs the best thing you can do is
cut them off
just lose their phone number don't
respond to the phone calls or the texts
i mean if you got to tell them you know
let them know but
get them just get them out of the way
again people on the outside they don't
matter let these spurgs
you know have their little spazz out
sessions with their little tiny crew of
losers making up [ __ ] about you
that isn't true let them spaz out it
doesn't matter
you know it's just hilarious number two
the self-entitled slacker they feel the
world
owes them attention and praise even
though they lack the discipline to do
the hard work
how many people do you know like that i
can
i would i would run out of counting on
my fingers and toes if i'm being honest
there's probably 20 people that i
that i've come across even in the last
few years that i
that i would label as a self-entitled
slacker anyway number three
the status friend this one's an
interesting one because
these are the guys that envy you first
and then they try to befriend you
so the status friend they always measure
people via social status they envy those
of a higher status and envy those who
enjoy
certain privileges so these are
privileges that
they're identifying with that they want
to enjoy but they see you enjoy
so you know they try to move in which
brings me to the fourth one
which is the attacher uh let me just go
to these questions real sec before i
deal with the
attacher raymond says it's like trying
to explain to a crow what it's like to
soar like an eagle they'll never get it
yeah it's like
trying to explain to a fly
you know that if you're a bumblebee and
you're trying to explain to a fly that
honey's better than [ __ ] they just don't
get it
the fly is going to pick [ __ ] because
that's what they are right
tuscan razorbacks this is great
production extremely beneficial it's
gold information
thanks brother appreciate that the
attacher
again guys if you want to hop on to the
stream
don't pile in at the end because that's
always what happens i've got like 20
guys waiting to
ask questions and i got to wrap up the
show because at 9 30 i have to move on
to my next project which is a private
call for my group
but there's a streamlight stream yard
link
click it join through a bunch of people
have been messaging me asking me
questions of my dms do them live it's
either book a call or
do them live here i'm before the train
wreck so the free option is live here
uh the attacher they don't have a
calling in life so they attach
themselves to people with a sense of
purpose
this ties into the status front they
envy and ultimately attack the person
they've attached to
so these guys are dangerous af
okay i mentioned earlier at the opening
the their key goal is to find your
weakness and how to hurt you
the attacher is one of the ways that
they'll go about it
i've had attachers they're like um
what are those sucker fish that are that
are always like uh
on top of sharks you know the sharks
swimming around and these things just
kind of suck onto them
on the top or bottom of them that's
basically what these losers are
they don't want to do the work in life
they don't they don't have a clear
calling
so they attach themselves to you so they
have some sort of sense of purpose they
envy and ultimately attack the person
that they've attached to
i've seen this happen time and time and
time
and time again yeah lampreys correct
yeah that's what they're called lampreys
uh alexander says i'm not black or red
pill that just enjoy your channel
because you have a positive message for
men
it's better to have a positive mindset
and hope to have
sorry and hope that i have a loser
mindset filled with despair
keep up the good work thanks alex
appreciate that yeah i agree
i mean a lot of people with their
different colored pills i
i did the show on the weekend with my
buddy paul on the stereo app and
some guy uh asked a question about the
white pill
it's like all right are we just making
up stuff now because it's like you know
we've made up genders we've made up you
know things that are
offensive i'm gonna be offended by
shampoo because i don't have hair it's
like you know people are just making up
[ __ ] now it's like let's
let's call it the white pill okay let's
just move on from that
so watch out for these attachers guys
okay and number five
uh adam i'll get to you in a sec i'd see
you there in the waiting area give me a
second
um not able to copy chat link to stream
here okay somebody that so
again guys if you're coming in late
here's the youtube link click the
youtube link because
apparently periscope with twitter
doesn't like taking it for some reason
head on over to youtube and join us
there smash a like button get those up
and i'll grab you the invite link
to ask a question live again
this is the stream yardling you can hop
on in a minute
um there's already people starting to
line up so don't
don't leave it the insecure master
they are an insecure person who holds a
high position in society
but secretly doubts their worth
therefore they envy more talented
subordinates
i've worked for a guy um like this who
was in a higher position i don't know
how he got there because he wasn't very
good
and remember i mean [ __ ] i was in my 20s
at this time
late 20s and i remember there was this
uh email that he had to send out
explaining something uh specific to
the vice president of the company he
didn't know how to articulate it
so he calls me in his office and he goes
here sit here uh you know coop and you
know fill this out
that's what he used to call me in the
street coop he goes you know fill this
out and you know send this over to the
vp and i'm like
isn't this your job like why am i doing
this for you sort of thing but
the guy always envied the work that i
did you know for my team so
not that dangerous of a guy i would i
mean if i would narrow it down i'd say
keep an eye open for the attachers
have a sober second thinker looking over
your shoulder making sure they got an
eye on you watch out for
self-entitled slackers and the most
important one which i think is the
biggest indicator which i've seen a
number of times in my life which did pop
up and was exposing to risk
was poisonous praise people uh again
that was displayed
disparaging comments cushioned his
praise so something like
they'll comment on how much money you're
going to make rather than praise your
hard work
for the completed project
you